خرجت في مدن وعواصم اوروبيه عده مسيرات
حاشده رفضا للحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه ففي
مدينه مانشستر البريطانيه خرج الالاف في
مسيره داعمه لفلسطين ومطالبه بوقف اطلاق
النار على
[موسيقى]
القطاع كما خرجت مظاهرات في الدنمارك دعما
للشعب الفلسطيني وتنديدا بالمجازر
الاسرائيليه
المظاهره خرجت ايضا في مدينه اوترخت
الهولنديه حمل المتظاهرون الاعلام
الفلسطينيه ونددوا باستمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي الوحشي على
غزه وفي مدينه ميلانو الايطاليه خرجت
مظاهرات
ايضا وفي العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس خرج جت
مظاهرات داعمه للشعب الفلسطيني ومند
بالعدوان الاسرائيلي المتواصل على
القطاع شهدت العاصمه الالمانيه برلين
تظاهره ندد فيها المحتجون بما يصفونه
بالعباده الجماعيه في غزه وطالبوا الحكومه
الالمانيه بالتوقف عن دعم اسرائيل تزامنت
هذه المظاهره مع مسيرات اخرى في مدينتي
شتوتغارت
وكولونيا طالبت بدورها بوقف فوري لاطلاق
في
غزه